for the second week in a row
international visitors got a special
welcome at mccarran airport yes
tonight's landing coming from london as
overseas flights return to the u.s after
more than a year away madison kimbrough
live tonight after hearing from those
who are arriving and departing madison
with more international travelers able
to visit vegas this might be the last
piece of the puzzle in regaining our
vegas economy back
i'm really relieved there's no place
else last week we saw virgin atlantic
airways come through with the return of
international flights and now british
airways resumed its flights at mccarran
with non-stop service from london for
many it's their first time back since
the start of the pandemic i left
actually march the 30th last year
so it's been nearly 20 months since
since i've been back in the us and with
more international travelers means the
opportunity for our vegas economy to
bounce back again we'll break we've had
lots of fun we've done our shopping and
now we're going home yeah ready to book
for next year according to lvcva vegas
saw almost 1.5 million european
travelers in 2019 and from the uk over
740 thousand tourists made the trip
vegas is a city that really relies on
people coming and having a great time
and spending hopefully lots of money
maybe not losing too much of it in the
casinos but i think it's it's wonderful
to be back and while everyone is happy
to be traveling again some worry that
due to the increasing number of coveted
cases in europe a travel ban will be put
in place again i think that the borders
will be closed again the situation in
europe especially in europe is going to
be worse
travelers arriving on british airways
were greeted with vegas swag from shirts
to hats to cookies and even masks also
you can't forget the vegas showgirl so
this definitely was a landing to
remember for sure reporting live from
mccarran international airport madison
kimbrough live local now